favorable qui est
pour qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté nous entamons
maintenant l'article 11 et je donne la
parole à Madame doanau allez-y chèci
monsieur le Président alors nous allons
changer voilà de sujets en quelque sorte
puisque là nous allons attaquer le
l'article 11 avant que que s'ouvre son
examen je tenais à rappeler quelques
éléments susceptibles d'éclairer les
débats sur l'article qui vise à réformer
en fait la clause de sauvegarde et à
fixer pour 2024 son seuil de
déclenchement on en a un petit peu déjà
parler le premier jour de de l'examen du
PLFSS il s'agit d'un enjeu important la
croissance soutenue des dépenses de
médicaments est un défi majeur pour
l'assurance maladie et certains l'ont
déjà dit sur ces bans depuis que nous
sommes en débat alimenté par le
vieillissement de la population
l'augmentation de la prévalence des
maladies chroniques et une grappe
d'innovation thérapeutique dont nous ne
voyons pour le moment que les prémisses
cette tendance devrait durer et
peut-être même
s'accélérer alors que les difficultés
d'approvisionnement s'accumulent chaque
hiver les enjeux sanitaires et de
souveraineté qui concentrent le secteur
sont par ailleurs
évidents conçue comme une corde de
rappel budgétaire par la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
9 vous voyez ça ne date pas d'hier la
clause de sauvegarde est devenue depuis
le milieu des années 2010 un véritable
dispositif fiscal pesant chaque année
sur les entreprises du médicament son
poids a considérablement augmenté ces
dernières années alors que le rendement
de la clause restait depuis 2015
inférieur à 200 millions d'euros il a
atteint 1 milliard d'euros en 2022 et
dépassera 1,5 milliard d'euros en 2023
comme en 2024
la clause de sauvegarde est ainsi
devenue ces dernières années un outil de
régulation des dépenses de médicaments à
partentière comparable aux baisses de
prix ou aux remises tarifaires négocié
avec les industriels chaque année or la
commission l'a plusieurs fois souligné
la clause de sauvegarde ne fait pas un
bon outil de régulation pourquoi
calculer l'année suivante dans le cas où
les dépenses auraient dépassé le seuil
prévu elle est d'abord imprévisible pour
les entreprises qui se plaignent de
l'incertitude dans laquelle elles sont
placées surtout la clause étant répartie
seulement en fonction la madame madame
la rapporteur oui mais je je serai plus
rapide sur l'ensemble des oui très
rapide surtout la clause étant répartie
seulement en fonction du chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises de leur
croissance elle ne tient compte d'aucun
impératif de s de santé publique ni
d'aucun des enjeux industriels attachés
à la production souveraine de
médicaments la Commission a souhaité
aborder cet article monsieur monsieur le
ministre de manière pragmatique elle
proposera de supprimer la réforme des
modalités de liquidation de la clause de
sauvegarde portée par l'article 11 qui
ne convainc pas les industriels et
n'apporte aucune réponse aux écueils que
j'ai décrit en revanche la Commission a
déposé et soutenu plusieurs amendements
qui visent à sécuriser le dispositif et
c'est indispensable mieux protéger les
médicaments essentiels à la prise en
charge des patients merci Madame la
rapporteur l'amendement 732 défendu par
Nam sis allez-y chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues à l'heure où les pénuies
de médicaments et l'augmentation
continue exponentielle des prix des
innovations thérapeutiques font rage la
priorité est au changement de nos
rapports avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
ainsi la clause de sauvegarde avait été
conçu comme un mécanisme incitatif à la
négociation de prix dans le cadre d'une
politique dite conventionnelle entre
l'État et l'industrie pharmaceutique ce
dispositif avait été revendiqué comme un
outil majeur de contrôle de prix le
PLFSS 2024 présenté ici vient non
seulement relever le montant m
c'est-à-dire le plafond de dépenses à
partir duquel la clause de sauvegarde
sera déclenchée mais aussi de baisser la
somme que les entreprises du médicament
sont censé reverser à l'assurance
maladie dans le cas où ce mécanisme
serait déclenché ce relâchement du
mécanisme de la clause de sauvegarde
vient annoncer à certaines recettes pour
l'assurance maladie sans des
contreparties transparentes vérifiables
et crédibles des entreprises de
médicaments princeps sur les baisses des
prix des innovations thérapeutiques si
la clause de sauvegarde c'est s'est
avéré un outil dysfonctionnel dans la
régulation des prix son affaiblissement
proposé dans le plfs S 2024 viendrait
rendre de dispositifs encore plus
inefficaces pour faire baisser les prix
des innovations thérapeutiques posant un
risque réel à ce que les entreprises de
médicaments prinp continuent à pratiquer
des prix
exorbitants la transformation de nos
politiques pharmaceutiques doit aller
dans le sens de la transparence du
marché pharmaceutique y compris des
coûts de la Red et de production afin de
pouvoir répondre convenablement au au
problèmes de régulation des prix des
innovations thérapeutiques la régulation
doit passer par un plafonnement
raisonnable des prix et des marges de
profit de l'industrie je propose donc de
supprimer l'article 11 pour que le
gouvernement produise un rapport
indépendant sur la production d'un
montant P fixant le seuil de profit des
entreprises de médicaments princeps
merci merci chers collègues madame la
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cet
amendement en fait l' vie est
défavorable parce que en supprimant
l'article et en le remplaçant par un
rapport on n'est pas du tout à ce que la
Commission a décidé chers collègues et
en plus vous euh ça ne permet pas non
plus de fixer le montant m et le montant
Z donc en réalité on on a quand même
beaucoup de manquement si on supprime
tout cet article merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement merci Monsieur le le
Président vous proposez en effet la la
suppression de de l'article 11 je
rappelle que ces évolutions de calcul
elles visent une chose contrairement à
ce que vous indiquez indiqué c'est de
simplifier le calcul de la clause et en
aucune façon de diminuer son rendement
la clause ne sera plus calculée sur la
base du chiffre d'affaires des
fabricants mais sur mais sur la base du
montant remboursé par l'assurance
maladie alors même que nous rencontrons
des des difficultés déclarative donc il
ne s'agit en aucune manière de revoir le
rendement mais bien une mesure de
simplification pour ces raisons-là
j'aiimis un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre je mets au voix cet
amendement 732 avec deux avis
défavorables de la Commission du
gouvernement qui est
pour merci qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté cher collègues nous passons
ensuite à 14 amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune et nous
commençons par deux amendements
identiques le premier est celui de la
commission le 243 madame la rapporteur
vous avez la
parole la rapporteur pardz- monsieur le
Président en fait cet amendement vise à
supprimer la réforme de l'assiette et
des modalités de liquidation de la
clause de sauvegarde des médic porté par
l'article 11 du PLFSS c'est ce que j'ai
dit un peu tout à l'heure déjà en
faisant dépendre à concurrence de 70 %
la contribution d par chaque entreprise
de sa part dans le montant remboursé par
l'Assurance Maladie cette réforme
concentre l'effort sur les industriels
dont le portefeuille est composé de
produits présentant un taux de prise en
charge élevé tel est le cas des
médicaments les plus indispensables à la
prise en charge des patients les
médicaments dispensés en ville qui
présentent un service médical rendu
important les médicaments innovants et
onéreux dispensés à l'hôpital et pris en
charge hors tarification à l'activité
les médicaments intervenants dans le
traitement d'une affectation d'une
affection de longue durée cet effet est
contraire aux préconisations de la
récente commission d'enquête sénatoriale
sur les pénuries de médicaments qui
invitait au contraire à mieux tenir
compte de l'intérêt thérapeutique des
médicaments et de leur criticité
industrielle dans l'application de la
clause de sauvegarde la Commission
invite le gouvernement à revoir cette
réforme sans renoncer à l'objectif
d'allègement des contraintes
déclaratives pour les entreprises
qu'elle entendait poursuivre avis
défavorable ah pardon pardon pardon
excusez-moi excusez-moi ils sont ils
sont en discussion commune
pardon l'amendement 373 monsieur Milon
défendu nous passons ensuite aux trois
rectifiés bis madameliman-y vous avez la
parole oui merci alors il s'agit d'un
amendement qui a été déposé à
l'initiative de notre collègue la
présidente Sassone est
donc il s'agit de sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des médicaments
matures on le sait les médicaments
matures sont à 70 % concernés par un
problème de pénurie un un récent rapport
sénatorial a révélé que la fabrication
de 700 médicaments matures pourrai être
abandonné en raison du fait que qu'ils
ne sont plus rentables financièrement
pour y remédier l'amendement propose de
déduire de l'assiette de calcul de la
clause de sauvegarde le premier euro
remboursé par la Sécurité Sociale et ce
sans préjudice du montant total de la
clause de sauvegarde qui serait donc
préservé merci merci le 170 monsieur
Milon merci monsieur le Président
introduite en 1999 dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
clause de sauvegarde est une
contribution collective qui est reversée
par l'industrie pharmaceutique lorsque
le chiffre affaire total du secteur
pharmaceutique dépasse le montant m voté
par la loi la clause de sauvegarde est
calculée au Pr d'importance du niveau de
dépassement du montant m l'article 11
qui porte une réforme de cette clause de
sauvegarde à partir de 2025 supprime la
progressivité du calcul de cette clause
et prévoit un taux unique de reversement
à 90 %. les travaux menés dans le durant
le prier semestre dans le cadre d'
mission régulation des produits de santé
mandaté par le la première ministre on
mis en avant la nécessité de remettre à
plat la politique de régulation
économique du médicament et notamment le
fonctionnement de cette clause de
sauvegarde en concertation avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes en
l'espèce aucune analyse ni étude
d'impact n'est fournie pour justifier
l'augmentation du taux de reversement à
90 % à partir de 2025 alors même que le
gouvernement s'est engagé à stabiliser
le niveau de régulation économique du
médicament qui a atteint des moments
historiques entre 2021 et 2023 3 à cet
égard à titre conservatoire le présent
amendement propose donc de maintenir un
taux unique de reversement à 70 % dans
l'attente de la présentation d'une étude
d'impact permettant de réajuster ce taux
de reversement à un niveau idouine merci
Monsieur Milon l'article l'amendement
pardon 1108 est présenté par Madame
Bonfanti salz-y chers collèg ou merci
monsieur le Président afin d'assurer la
souveraineté en matière de médicaments
et de sécuriser l'approvisionnement de
nos concitoyens il est proposer de tenir
compte du lieu de production des
médicaments concernés en créant une
troisème tranche ce critère permet de
contribuer à l'objectif essentiel de
sauvegarde de la santé publique il
s'inscrit pleinement dans le plan France
2030 qui prévoit la relocalisation et
l'augmentation des capacités de
production de médicaments et dans la
continuation de la loi relative à
l'industrie verte visant une nouvelle
étape de
réindustrialisation du du pays il permet
également de prendre en compte la
contrainte qui pèse sur tout titulaire
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché et
toute entreprise pharmaceutique
exploitant un médicament en France de
constituer un stock de
médicaments merci nous passons à
l'amendement 674 madame Romani vous avez
la
parole merci président l'amendement que
je je propose est en tout point le même
que celui de Madame Bonfanti euh
simplement pour
pouvoir donner un peu plus de
justification à cet amendement à l'heure
de la réindustrialisation de la France
et où nous devons consommer français euh
je vous suggère chers collègues de voter
pour cet amendement merci chers
collègues le 16 rectifier bis monsieur
Milon
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit en fait dans l'article 11 au
niveau de l'alinéa 17 compléter cet
alinéa par les mots à l'exception des
médicaments mentionné au a du 15 de
l'article L 51 21 du Code de Santé
publique qui concerne les biosimilaires
merci nous passons ensuite au 1225
madame vouirol
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
proposons par cet amendement nous de
supprimer l'alinéa 20 de cet article
puisque vous le savez cet article ça
vient d'être explicité pré 11 prévoit
d'aligner le fonctionnement du mécanisme
de la clause de sauvegarde du médicament
sur celui du dispositif Mical qui est
Lee le mécanisme existant actuellement
ainsi le seuil de déclenchement de la
clause de sauvegarde ne reposera plus
sur le chiffre d'affaires net déclarés
par les entreprises mais au regard des
montants remboursés nets par l'assurance
maladie la CGT estime que ce nouveau
modèle de calcul permettra aux grands
groupes pharmaceutiques de réaliser des
économies évalué à 35 % de leurs
bénéfices et je sais faire le
différentiel entre les Big Pharma et
l'ensemble des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont installées sur
notre sol c'est donc pour nous un cadeau
offert aux grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques et aussi dans un souci
donc de préserver les ressources pour la
solidarité nationale qui nous l'avons vu
en on bien besoin nous proposons par cet
amendement de supprimer le plafonnement
du montant dû par une entreprise au
titre de la clause m à maximum 12 % du
montant total remboursé par l'Assurance
Maladie un tel plafond nous semble
parfaitement injustifié puisque à titre
d'exemple au prier tri
2022 le laboratoire American Pfizer a
enregistré un chiffre d'affaires de 27
milliards de dollars avec une hausse de
77 % à 1 an au 1er trimestre 2020 Sanofi
que nous connaissons bien a publié un
résultat net d'activité en hausse de
15,9 % par rapport à la même période
l'année précédente c'est-à-dire 2,042
milliards d'euros au regard de ces
chiffres et au regard donc à la
concentration du secteur et donc de ces
big pharmas l'existence d'un tel
plafonnement ne paraît pas nous paraît
inapproprié et priverait la sécurité
sociale de précieuses ressources nous
l'avons vu depuis hier hier au soir la
question de la création de nouvelles
recettes reste tabou pour le
gouvernement mais peut-être n'est-il pas
utile de supprimer celle ou de diminuer
celle qui existe chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous présentez
l'amendement 1328 s'il vous
plaît merci Monsieur le le président cet
amendement il vise à alléger la
contribution au titre de la clause de
sauvegarde des laboratoires exploitant
des spécialités génériques et qui
présentent naturellement des des marges
plus faibles pour inciter justement les
acteurs actuel et d'Ares acteurs à
s'investir sur ces nouveaux produits
donc la mesure proposée est un
plafonnement de la contribution
imputable à ces médicaments pour une
entreprise donnée elle ne pourra pas
excéder 2 % du chiffre d'affaires
réalisé donc avec ce mécanisme plus le
chiffre d'affaires d'une entreprise est
composé de médicaments génériquees plus
l'allègement de la contribution sera
important je rajoute également que cet
amendement précise que ce mécanisme ne
remet pas en cause le rendement global
de la clause de de sauvegarde ainsi
l'allègement de la contribution du sur
les médicaments génériques sera compensé
par la contribution du sur les autres
médicaments pour garantir la souten é de
notre
système merci Madame la rapporteur pour
le sous-amendement
1373 alors l'amendement 1328 vise à
plafonner la contribution du par les
entreprises au titre des médicaments on
parle bien des médicaments génériques et
médicaments de référence soumis à un
tarif forfaitaire de responsabilité
qu'elle commercialise à 2 % du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé par ces médicaments
ce faisant il vise à mieux protéger ces
médicaments du poids de la clause de
sauvegarde le présent sous-amendement
étant le champ d'application des
dispositions proposé en appliquant
également le plafond de 2 % au
médicaments de référence dont le prix
fabricant hors taxe est inférieur à 5 €
qui ne serait pas génériqué ce faisant
il vise à mieux protéger du poids de la
régulation l'ensemble des produits
matures peu cher et peu rentable qui
concentrent les difficultés
d'approvisionnement observé ces
dernières années
merci l'amendement 912 madame Brulin
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'alinéa 23
de cet article 11 le gouvernement ça a
été rappelé avait proposé en 2019
d'instaurer l'obligation pour les firmes
pharmaceutiques de porter à la
connaissance du comité économique des
produits de santé le montant des
investissements publics de recherche et
de développement dont elles ont
bénéficié pour les médicaments
susceptibles d'être admis au
remboursement avant que le conseil
constitutionnelle censure la disposition
malgré un chiffre d'affaires en
progression constante l'industrie
pharmaceutique critique depuis toujours
cette clause de sauvegarde en pointant
le cas des génériques initialement
exclus du montant m les mécanismes de
régulation des prix des médicaments
viennent contrecarrer l'absence de
transparence dans la fixation des prix
des médicaments et principalement
l'absence de transparence des dépenses
de communication par exemple des
médicaments en conclusion la clause de
sauvegarde est un mécanisme de
régulation des prix des médicaments qui
participe à la politique de soutien au
secteur de l'industrie pharmaceutique
cette nouvelle formule de calcul de la
clause de sauvegarde proposée par le
gouvernement ne répond ni au besoins de
transparence de fixation des prix des
médicaments ni à la juste contribution
des industriels ni enfin un véritable
pilotage de la politique de médicament
et ne répondra en rien au problèmes de
pénurie que nous rencontrons j'ai cru
comprendre madame la rapporteur que vous
aviez dans votre propos liminaire décrit
que cette cette clause de sauvegarde
avait au départ été imaginée pour ne pas
pour contenir on va dire des dépenses de
médicaments et que elle s'était peu à
peu transformé en un dispositif fiscal
mais ça c'est simplement le fait de
l'explosion des profits dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui a conduit à cette
transformation là et donc euh au moment
où plusieurs collègues l'ont dit euh les
les revenus sont extraordinaires dans ce
type d'industrie et qu'on connaît en
parallèle des pénuries il nous semble
important de ne pas se déposséder de ces
ressources collègue monsieur Milon pour
le 457 s'il vous
plaît merci monsieur le Président dans
un contexte marqué par l'inflation et la
hausse des dépenses de de médicaments
lié à la fois à la hausse de de la
consommation tirée évidemment par le
vieillissement de la population et à
l'arrivée de nouveaux médicaments
innovants dont les prix sont souvent
plus élevés la amendement que nous que
je présente avec les collègues garantit
la neutralité financière pour chaque
entreprise de la révision du périmètre
de calcul de la contribution au titre de
la clause de sauvegarde merci le 863
madame guidz madame guidz le
allez-y merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement sécurise et clarifie une
procédure déjà existante en effet les
laboratoires redevables de la
contribution m ne déclarant pas dans les
délais impartis peuvent se voir
attribuer une taxe à partir de leur
montant remboursé fixé par l'union de
recouvrement des cotisations de sécurité
sociale la base légale actuellement
utilisée est l'article L r pardon 138-23
du code de la sécurité sociale
l'objectif de cet amendement est de
sécuriser et de préciser cette procédure
en introduisant cette disposition dans
le texte relative à la clause de
sauvegarde l'article L r décidément
t138-23 du code de la sécurité sociale
est actuellement appliqué ainsi l'impact
financier attendu de cette mesure est
nul merci chers collègue madame
maschelan pour le 592
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues il
s'agit d'avancer la date d'entrée en
vigueur de l'article 11 euh et pour
rappel cet article 11 vise à fiabiliser
les données utilisées pour le calcul de
la du montant de la attribution au titre
de la clause de sauvegarde et l'objectif
évident c'est de bien sûr un intérêt
économique pour les comptes publics en
fiabilisant les données pour permettre
le recouvrement de ces montants merci
merci et enfin le dernier amendement le
368 monsieur
Milon je vais demander à la rapporteur
l'avis de la commission sur ces 14
amendements on commence par les deux
amendements identiques 243 et 373 vous
avez la parole madame la raorteur
oui merci monsieur le Président donc je
vais pas revenir sur l'objet que chacun
a présenter à travers ces amendements je
vais vous dire qu'en fait nous ce que
nous avons souhaité en sous-amendant euh
le l'amendement du Gouvernement c'est
d'une part de de supprimer la réforme
parce que celle-ci apparaît en effet
inefficace pour simplifier la procédure
et alléger les contraintes déclaratives
des entreprises leur représentant que
nous avons auditionné doute qu'elle
permett d'accélérer et de sécuriser la
liquidation de la clause de sauvegarde
surtout en concentrant la crise la
clause de sauvegarde sur les médicaments
les mieux pris en charge et d'ailleurs
ça a été redit par les uns ou les
autres la réforme reporte le poids de ce
dispositif sur les médicaments les plus
indispensables à la prise en charge des
patients c'est pourquoi la commission a
émis un avis favorable à l'égard de
l'amendement de Monsieur Milon qui est
en fait identique euh à celui de la
Commission visant à supprimer la réforme
et inviter le gouvernement à la
retravailler pour simplifier réellement
les contraintes des entreprises et mieux
tenir compte des enjeux de santé
publique dans la clause de sauvegarde
d'autre part la commission vous propose
de protéger davantage de la clause de
sauvegarde certains médicaments
essentiels et là encore je réponds à
certains de vos amendements depuis
plusieurs années elle a soutenue des
amendements visant à réduire la charge
pesant sur les médicaments génériques
considérant que ceci permettait déjà à
l'Assurance Maladie de réaliser des
économie substantielle en cohérence et
dans la mesure où cet amendement réduit
Dr drastiquement l'application de la
clause au générique dès 2024 par
l'instauration d'un plafond de 2 % la
commission a émis un avis favorable à
l'égard de l'amendement numéro 1328 du
gouvernement sous réserve de l'adoption
de notre sous-amendement celui-ci
permettra d'étendre la mesure au
médicaments de référence dans le Prix
fabriquant hors taxe est inférieur à 5 €
et de limiter ainsi le poids de la
régulation sur les médicaments matures
les moins chers qui concentrre les
difficultés d'approvisionnement il
s'agit d'une préconisation de la récente
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur la
pénurie de médicaments considérant que
ces deux objectifs atteints par
l'amendement et le sous-amendement
qu'elle porte la commission a donc émis
un avis défavorable sur l'ensemble des
autres amendements mais qui trouveront
quelque part leur plénitude à travers ce
que nous
proposons merci donc nous nous avons
bien compris que si l'amendement
sous-amendé par la Commission passe tous
les autres amendements tombent je vais
demander l'avis au au gouvernement sur
d'abord le 243
oue c'est
bon je vais faire une une réponse sur le
243 je voulais faire une réponse globale
sur tous les amendements mais en effet
selon je comprends le vote du 243 ça
pourrait tout faire tomber
euh madame la rapporteur général et puis
l'amendement de de Monsieur Milon donc
l'objectif du du changement d'assiette
je l' évoqué en réponse à un amendement
précédent c'est bien d'avoir une
assiette plus simple je le redis qui ne
repose pas sur les déclarations de
chiffrre d'affaires des entreprises
puisque c'est une obligation déclarative
pour les entreprises en s'appuyant sur
une donnée disponible maîtrisée par
l'administration c'est bien les dépenses
remboursées par l'Assurance Maladie donc
c'est une c'est une opération
simple automatique sans erreur
déclarative sans charge administrative
et je sais que les uns les autres vous
êtes très attentif au aux charges
administratives sur sur les entreprises
d'autre part donc c'est une mesure de
simplification d'autre part ce n'est pas
une mesure de rendement c'est-à-dire
qu'en modifiant le calcul de cette
clause on ne change pas le
rendement et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle vous avez à la fois la
base qui change et les taux que vous
avez vu changer tout simplement pour
assurer la neutralité financière pour
les entreprises premier élément deuxème
élément ensuite il peut y avoir des
effets redistributifs ce que j'exliquais
tout à l'heure c'est comme on va aider
davantage ça c'est l'amendement du
Gouvernement les génériqueurs il peut y
avoir un effet sur les autres sur les
autres produits et je crois que nous
partageons cette cet objectif d'autre
part madame la rapporteur générale vous
dites il n'y a pas eu de concer ation
suffisante permettez-moi de de rappeler
plusieurs éléments la première c'est que
c'est la traduction concrète et direct
d'un rapport qui s'appelle pour un New
Deal qui a mis autour de la table des
personnalités qualifié d'horizon très
différent qui ont travaillé pendant des
mois auditionné pendant des mois et sont
arrivés à cette proposition là donc il y
a vraiment eu un travail très profond
très long que le ministre de la Santé de
la prévention en amont du projet les
lois de de finances que que nous
discutons aujourd'hui a mené lui-même
des
concertations et d'autre part la mesure
ne sera mise en vigueur effectivement
qu'en 2026 ce qui laisse le temps encore
pour poursuivre les discussions la
pédagogie la
concertation donc j'insiste il a
véritablement eu un travail préparatoire
extrêmement euh
important et je pense que j'ai réagi
effectivement aux deux amendements sur
lesquel vous me demandez mon avis donc
c'est un avis défavorable plutôt je
dirais une demande de retrait sinon un
avis
défavorable je question
euh sur l'amendement 243 chers collègues
je vous informe que si cet amendement de
la commission est adopté il fait tomber
les amendements 3 rectifié bis madame
Estrosi Sasson l'amendement 912 de
Madame Brulin le 457 de Monsieur Milon
et le 863 de M madame guidz je vais le
mettre au voix qui est pour l'amendement
243 qui est
contre il est
adopté nous passons ensuite à une série
d'amendements je signale leurs auteurs
que c'est ces amendements sont
contraires au sous-amendement de la
condition de la Commission et que si il
passe c'est le sous-amendement de la
commission qui qui tombe donc je vais
vous demander si vous les maintenez ou
pas on va faire ça dans l'ordre le 3
rectifié bis il est retiré vous le
maintenez est-ce que vous voulez que je
réexlique il est tombé pardon celui-là
est tombé non c'est le
170 monsieur
Milan retirer le
1108 même chose le 674 madame
Romani retiré le 16 rectifié bis
monsieur Milon retiré le 1225 madame
pouirol vous le maintenez donc on va le
mettre aux voix qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il n'est
pas adopté nous passons ensuite au
sous-amendement de la commission
c'est-à-dire le
1373 que je mets au vote monsieur le
ministre vous avez pas donné votre avis
allez-y
maintenant monsieur le Président je sais
que Madame la rapporteur générale y
tient mais je voudrais signaler quelques
difficultés avec le le sous-amendement
et j'espère avoir je le dis plus de
succès qu'avec avec ma pldoirie
précédente vous souhaitez et je crois
qu'on partage C cette obj tif CR un
plafonnement et étendre le plafonnement
au médicament de référence de moins de 5
€ qui ne serait pas
génériqué et vous voulez protéger les
médicaments matures
essentiel pour beaucoup de de
pathologies c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi
nous prévoyant l'article 6 du 36 du
PLFSS et et vous aurez en débattre un
dispositif de reprise d'activités en cas
d'arrêt de commercialisation de certains
médicaments mais j'en viens surtout à la
difficulté que que que que me pose votre
amendement la en étendant le dispositif
que je vous ai décrit pour les
médicaments génériques au médicaments de
moins de 5 € vous créez un effet de
seuil qui peut inciter les laboratoires
ayant un prix proche de 5 € à augmenter
leur prix à ce niveau là pour bénéficier
du dispositif et puis surtout nous
allons constater un effet quasi immédiat
c'est le changement de
conditionnement pour pouvoir bénéficier
de ce seuil de de 5 € une boîte qui
serait je sais pas à 10 € bah on fait
deux boîtes à 5 et on rentre dans dans
le dispositif les médicaments de moins
de 5 € sont très variés alors que
l'amendement proposé par le gouvernement
j'insiste permet de cibler les
génériques c'est ça qu'on veut aider
compris pour limiter les dépenses de de
de de de médicaments donc vraiment
j'insiste je prense qu'il y a dans votre
sous-amendement si j'en comprends
l'intention des risques de contournement
des risques d'effet non maîtrisés qui
finiraient par s'éloigner de l'objectif
que que l'on poursuit donc c'est un un
avis
défavorable
merci je vous en prie madame la
rapporteur allez-y
oui alors moi je je je crois pas trop à
vos explications monsieur le ministre
pardonnez-moi la première chose vous dit
ce serait inciter finalement les
industriels à aller vers ce
seuil ça c'est peut-être l'argument qui
qui fait plutôt
mais en même temps je je suis sceptique
sur cet élément-l le deuxième élément
c'est le conditionnement or les
conditionnements ils sont déjà
préconisés par la Haute Autorité de
Santé donc je vois pas en quoi là les
les choses pourraient changer et pour
autant nous ce qu'on veut protéger c'est
ceux qui ne sont pas génériques enfin
les médicaments non génériques mais qui
sont à bas prix justement donc c'est
pour cette raison que nous avons posé ce
sous-amendement merci je mettre au voix
ce sous-amendement de la commission qui
est
pour qui est contre il est adopté je met
ensuite au voix l'amendement du
Gouvernement sous-amendé par le
sous-amendement de la commission qui est
pour qui est contre il est adopté nous
passons ensuite à
l'amendement tombe pardon
592 et
368 tombe et nous arrivons à
l'amendement 130 rectifié bis monsieur
Milon vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président le
dispositif de régulation issue de la
clause de sauvegarde qui vise cette fois
à encadrer la croissance à l'hôpital des
dépenses remboursé sur la liste enensus
lié au dispositifs médicaux doit être
selon nous revu dans son mécan
aucun outil de pilotage monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre ni aucune
instruction de la part du ministère de
la Santé de la prévention ou du
ministère deéconomie n'existe ou n'est
prévu à date pour anticiper un potentiel
recouvrement de la clause si la hausse
des dépenses en DM à l'hôpital est
amenée à déclencher la clause de
sauvegarde il convient d'en étudier les
facteurs pour en tenir compte
ultérieurement dans la méthodologie de
calcul du montant Z et apporter la
lisibilité la prévisibilité au secteur
du DM visé par l'obligation de
contribution cette identification des
facteurs de dépassement se justifie
d'autant plus que la hausse du montant
des dépenses remboursées n'est pas
corrélée à une surutilisation des
dispositifs médicaux mais s'explique par
une évolution des besoins de santé d à
des changements organisationnels
sanitaires ou technologiques que connaît
le système de santé le présent
amendement vise donc à ce que lorsque le
déplacement du montant Z est constaté
l'assurance maladie transmet m dans un
délai de 3 mois au ministre chargé des
solidarité sociale et au Parlement un
rapport identifiant et analysant les
facteurs de ce dépassement ce rapport
devra permettre de l'élaboration d'un
outil de pilotage de la clause mais
également contribuer à la mise en place
des mécanismes correctifs permettant de
renforcer la prévisibilité et la
stabilité de la régulation et
l'émergence de l'innovation en France
une réévaluation du montants Z pourra
notamment être envisagée à l'essue du
rapport sur le modèle de révoluation du
montant m dans le présent pfss en cas
d'écart constaté entre la courbe de
croissance théorique des dépenses et
celle de croissance tête je sais
Monsieur monsieur le Président que c'est
une demande de rapport mais c'est pas
une demande de rapport au gouvernement
c'est le constat à faire faire par
l'assurance maladie des dépenses
constaté que ce constat doit être
transmis et au gouvernement et au
Parlement Milon quel est l'avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur l'avis
est défavorable favorable l'avis du
Gouvernement déforable défavorable aussi
je mets au au voie cet amendement 130
avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre il est adopté nous passons
ensuite à l'amendement présenté au nom
de la commission au Affaires Culturelles
par Madame la rapporteur vous avez la
parole alors cet amendement social
excusez-moi excusez-moi des affaires
sociales j'ai dit culturel je vous
incorporé à ma commission allez-y
allez-y pour pas c'est pas un changement
que j'ai prévu dans l'immédiat mais bon
alors donc l'amendement vise à rendre
applicable à la clause de sauvegarde des
dispositifs médicaux certaines des
garanties envisagées dans le cadre de la
réforme de la clause de sauvegarde des
médicaments il précise notamment que
l'assurance maladie et le comité
économique des produits de santé doivent
transmettre à l'acosse avant le 15
juillet de l'année N+1 les informations
permettant la liquidation de la clause
de sauvegarde ces derniers sont
transmises sans délai par la COS aux
entreprises concernées le retard
accumulé dans la liquidation de la
clause de sauvegarde des dispositifs
médicaux pour 2022 est venu rappeler la
nécessité de sécuriser la procédure de
liquidation et d'améliorer la
prévisibilité de la clause pour les
entreprises merci quel est l'avis du du
gouvernement sur cet amendement de la
commission monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur le merci
monsieur le Président donc votre
amendement madame la rapporteur générale
vise à anticiper les délaiis de
transmission à la cause et données
nécessaires au calcul à liquidation de
la clause de sauvegarde vous souhaitez
que la date limite de transmission soit
avancée du 30 septembre au 15 juillet de
l'année N+1 moi je partage bien
évidemment notre objectif de sécuriser
la liquidation et je renvoie au débat
que nous avions encore il y a quelques
minutes sur les sur les sur les réformes
possibles pour sécuriser et améliorer la
liquidation de de la clause mais après
exper madame la rapporteur général il
apparaît que les délais que vous
proposez ne peuvent être mis en œuvre
par la CNAM et le CEPS par exemple la
CNAM ne dispose pas avant le 15 juillet
des données consolidées sur les dépenses
de dispositifs médicaux à l'hôpital pour
cette raison je vous propose de retirer
votre amendement sinon je serai
défavorable merci je mets au voix cet
amendement 244 avec un avis défavorable
du gouvernement qui est
pour merci qui est contre
il est
adopté nous passons ensuite à deux
amendements identiques le premier le 127
monsieur Milon vous avez la parole oui
merci monsieur le Président je vais
laisser ma collègue l sarade présenter
cet amendement je dirais juste que cette
proposition d'amendement s'incrit en
cohérence avec la recommandation E14 du
rapport de la mission borne sur la
régulation et le financement des des
produits de santé publié en août 2023
dont les préconisations ont vocation à
se concrétiser au travers des lois de
financement de la séc sociale merci
Madame la sarade pour le
407 merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Milon dans un contexte de
déclenchement imminent de la clause de
sauvegarde du dispositif médical pour
l'année 2022 le dispositif de régulation
issue de la clause de sauvegarde qui
vise à encadrer la croissance à
l'hôpital des dépenses remboursées sur
la liste en sus lié au dispositifs
médicaux doit être revu dans son
mécanisme en effet le modèle de
recouvrement de la clause fondé sur un
taux unique de contribution apparaît
comme un mécanisme dont la rigidité
renvoie un message fortement
désincitatif pour la diffusion des
produits de santé innovants en France
cette situation est d'autant plus
pénalisante que la hausse du montant des
dépenses remboursées dis montant Z n'est
pas exclusivement corrélé à une
surutilisation ou à un mésusage des
dispositifs médicaux elle s'explique
également par une évolution des besoins
de santé d à des changements
organisationnels comme le virage atoire
sanitaire chronicité des maladies ou
encore technologique prise en charge
innovante que connaît le système de
santé il apparaît ainsi nécessaire de
prévoir des des aménagements
circonstanciés de ce mécanisme pour
d'une part assurer la la prévisibilité
et la stabilité de la régulation et
d'autre part le rendre moins pénalisant
pour l'émergence de l'innovation en
France cet amendement vise donc à
proposer une évolution du modèle de la
clause de sauvegarde des dispositifs
médicaux prenant en compte le risque
accru de son déclenchement afin
d'intoduire un barême de taux progressif
de contribution défini par voie
réglementaire merci chers collègues quel
est l'avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements identiques s'il vous plaît
alors je voudrais vous vous signaler
chers collègues que dans l'article 11
ter du PLFSS donc qui va suivre là
retenu par le gouvernement il est permis
déjà de réduire le taux à applicable à
la part du montant remboursé excédant le
montant Z de 100 % à 90 % et la
Commission va proposer en outre à ce
même article d'augmenter le seuil de
déclenchement Z pour 2023 et pour 2024
en conséquence et dans la mesure où nous
modérons déjà le poids de la clause de
sauvegarde par d'autres moyens pour ces
deux années la commission a émis un avis
défavorable pour ces deux amendements
merci Monsieur le Ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement merci merci Monsieur le le
président madame la sénatrice le
pourcentage de dépassement du montant Z
qui détermine le montant de la
contribution du sera déjà baissé de 100
% à 90 % je considère que comp tenu de
de cette déjà de cet engagement il n'est
pas nécessaire d'aller plus loin donc
j'ai met un avis défavorable à votre
amendement merci monsieur le ministre je
mets au voie ces deux amendements
identiques je le retire les deux sont
retirés oui sont retirés monsieur Milon
s'il vous plaît un petit instant donc
l'amendement 15 rectifi bis est
contraire à l'amendement du Gouvernement
sous-amendé par la commission telle que
vous l'avez adopté donc je vous
suggérerai de le retirer c'est fait
merci Monsieur Minan nous passons
ensuite à l'amendement 245 de la
commission madame la rapporteur vous
avez la parole alors je vous ai déjà un
petit peu expliqué le le sujet puisque
en cohérence avec l'amendement proposé à
l'article 4 dont nous avons débattu le
premier jour de cet examen et bien on
augmente le seuil de déclenchement de la
clause de sauvegarde des dispositifs
médicaux alors on a parlé du montant m
pour les médicaments là on parle du
montant
zin et et donc c'est au titre de 2023
pour tenir compte de l'incertitude
pesant sur le secteur et de l'effet de
rattrapage de son chiffre d'affaires
après la crise sanitaire le présent
amendement vise à augmenter le montant Z
pour 2024 en le portant à 2,45 milliards
d'euros ce nouveau montant est obtenu en
maintenant le taux d'évolution entre
2023 et
2024 de 4,5 % retenu par le gouvernement
et en l'appliquant au montant Z pour
2023 rectifié il permettra le cas
échéant de maîtriser l'effet d'un
éventuel déclenchement de la clause de
sauvegarde des dispositifs médicaux au
titre de l'année 2024 et de mesurer les
conséquences d'une telle taxation sur le
secteur avant toute augmentation
comparable à celle de la clause de
sauvegarde des
médicaments merci quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cette amendement de la
commission monsieur le ministre merci
Monsieur le le président madame la
rapporteur générale concernant les
dispositifs médicaux le montant Z a été
défini pour 2023 et 2024 à des niveaux
supérieurs même à ceux qui était prévu
dans France innovation 2030 aussi un
nouveau réhaussement tel que vous le
proposez du montant Z ne serait pas
soutenable pour l'assurance maladie et
je sais que vous êtes attaché à la
soutenabilité de la sécurité sociale et
en particulier de sa branche maladie
donc c'est un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
je mets au voix cet amendement de la
commission numéro 245 avec un avis
négatif du gouvernement qui est
pour merci qui est contre il est adopté
nous passons ensuite à l'amendement 951
madame Brulin merci monsieur le
Président l'article 11 prévoit que la
contribution d au titre du au titre de
l'année 2024 ne peut excéder pour chaque
entreprise 10 % de son chiffre
d'affaires diminuer des remises prises
en compte dans le calcul de l'assiette
de la clause de sauvegarde les
entreprises du médicament qui n'ont pas
pris beaucoup de décisions
d'amélioration de la prévention des
risques de rupture de stock doivent être
mises à contribution pour participer à
la solidarité de l'ensemble de notre
système de santé cet amendement vise
donc à supprimer la la limitation du
montant de la contribution du parchaque
industriel du médicament à 10 % de son
chiffre d'affaires merci merci chers
collègues quel est l'avis de la
commission
oui le plafond de de contribution
applicable aux entreprises pour 2024 que
le gouvernement a retenu dans le texte
sur lequel il a engagé sa responsabilité
permet déjà de prendre en compte des
remises consenties par chaque entreprise
à l'Assurance Maladie un tel
renforcement avait été en 2023 soutenu
par la commission il permet de maîtriser
le poids de la clause de sauvegarde et
de mieux tenir compte des efforts
consentis par chaque entreprise en
conséquence la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur votre proposition merci
Monsieur le Ministre défavorable
défavorable aussi je mets au voie cet
amendement 951 avec deux avis négatifs
de la Commission et du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
je vais mettre enite su au voit la
totalité de l'article
11 qui est
pour qui est
contre l'article 11 est
adopté nous passons ensuite à
l'amendement
1289 qui est soutenu par Madame Bell
Malaisie chers
collègue merci merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues cet amendement
vise à encourager l'emploi de la marche
de gros pour financer la tenue de stock
d'avance dans les outremèes en raison
d'un cas C inadapté pour les outremes